what i got an 80. that's ridiculous
hey guys i'm back at it and as you know
from the position that i'm sitting in
i'm about to do something on the
computer and that's take a kid's
health quiz because i've taken an idiot
test before and i failed
you recommended that i do buzzfeed
medical quizzes and i think those are
going to be too hard so i took on
something my own level
kids health i'm talking about a health
quiz for children if with my doctorate
degrees i can't get a hundred on all of
these
i should be embarrassed i kind of have a
feeling i will be
[Music]
how much do you know about the heart
find out by taking this quiz and again
this is meant to be for kids
how many chambers does the heart have
the heart has four chambers
two atria two ventricles atria are on
top ventricles are on bottom watch this
bam
all right they don't even tell you if i
got it right or wrong or not let's see
what happens
the movement of blood through the heart
and body is called
circulation locomotion
ventriculation or heart pump this is a
pretty easy one
locomotion is what a train does
ventriculation
sounds like something your ventricles
might do harp up no idea
circulation a final answer okay question
number three the beating sound your
heart makes
comes from blood going in the wrong
direction that sounds problematic
b valves closing c the heart skipping
beats
your ears playing tricks on you it's
valves closing
up with circulation the heart provides
your body
with oxygen nutrients a way to get rid
of waste
or all of the above well let's take
these one at a time oxygen
all of the cells in your body require
oxygen nutrients
the cells in your body require nutrients
getting rid of waste
every time your body makes use of a
nutrient there's always a waste product
how you can get rid of it your kidneys
how they're gonna get there
i love blood the atria are the upstairs
chambers of the heart and these parts
are the downstairs chambers well like we
said earlier
you got the atria up top ventricles
chilling on the bottom bunk i want to go
with b
ventricles final answer question six
what wall separates the left side and
the right side of the heart the
ventricle which we just said
is the basement the atria which we just
called the attic
the septum i'm not going to get into and
the great walls what's what found in
china
so go and see septum final answer
question seven
what parts act like the doors that
control blood flow
in the heart heart dams heart damn
kidneys
chambers yeah it's valves final answer
what organ removes waste from the blood
the heart well we all know the heart
pumps blood it's a muscle so ain't
removing waste
lungs kind of so this is kind of a trick
question because co2 is kind of
waste kidneys final answer they remove
waste
you can keep your heart strong by eating
heart-shaped candy
doing activities like playing outside
riding your bike and swimming
c smoking d sleeping 18 hours a day
playing outside riding your bike and
swimming what are the tubes that carry
blood back to the heart called
tubas pipes b veins a arteries
a carry blood away veins bring blood
back what's the difference between
arteries and veins while veins are thin
walled
arteries are more muscular why because
arteries sort of need to help contract
and push that blood away from the heart
veins are sort of just tubes that allow
blood to go back
and they have valves inside of them so
each time the heart pumps they open
and the blood cell doesn't fall back
down the valve's closed
i got a hundred i've got a hundred
on a kids quiz with a doctor in
if i get one of these wrong you guys can
jump me in the comment section muscles
quiz come on
let's do it the three major types of
muscles in the body
are smooth muscle sports muscle cardiac
muscle
running muscle and flexible muscle the
answer is b smooth muscle cardiac muscle
and skeletal muscle
two the muscle that pumps blood
throughout your body is
the heart cardiac which muscle helps you
move your shoulders
let's talk about it smooth muscle
where's that found not your shoulders
that's not skeletal muscles smooth
muscles like in your stomach
quadriceps you know where that is your
legs your upper thighs
tendons are what muscles use to attach
to bone as opposed to ligaments which
attach bones
to bones deltoid muscle are the little
caps around your shoulders
that helps move your shoulders which
type of muscle is found in your
digestive system oops gave it away
smooth muscle yeah what connects bones
and muscles together god i'm giving all
of them away
tendons oh it says glue elmer's skeletal
muscles work with bones to give your
body
strength the ability to move strength
and the ability to move
and all the above skeletal muscles give
you strength
and the ability to move yeah some of
your biggest
and most powerful muscles are in your
calves and thighs
in your back near your spine in your
arms or in your fingers
the strongest muscle in your body is
your calf has been measured
scientifically the answer is calves and
thighs which muscles are found on the
front of your thighs
quads biceps pecs or deltoids let's
start from bottom up as we've done
before
deltoids shoulder caps pecs
boom biceps boom quadriceps
front of your thighs which muscles are
found in your belly
and sometimes called abs they're called
abs because the proper medical term for
them is rectus abdominis when you make a
muscle in your arm
you are flexing your biceps and you know
why the bicep
is called bicep and the tricep is called
the tricep it's because there's
multiple heads the bicep has two heads
the tricep has three heads and the quads
have four heads
what i got an 80. that's ridiculous
they said the the most powerful muscles
are in your spine that is a lie
i've seen the study that your gastroc
is your strongest muscle i'm pulling up
the study right now
before i lose my mind hold on a second i
definitely miss clicked on something
yeah wait where's the other one that i
got wrong i only got one wrong why did i
get an 80. number one right
number two right number three right
number four right
number five right number six right
number seven wrong
number eight right number nine right and
number ten right
what is this game cheating me this is
ridiculous strongest
muscle you're gonna see a couple things
you can see the tongue and then the
gastroc
the muscle that can pull with the
greatest force
this is a government website by the way
i'm gonna pull this up just to make it
very clear there is no one answer for
the strongest muscle in the human body
since there are different ways
the muscle that can pull up can pull
with the greatest force
is the soleus it is found below the
gastroc
calf muscle the soleus is very important
for walking running and dancing
it's considered a very powerful muscle
along with calf muscles
because it pulls against the force of
gravity to keep the body upright
now the other one is the gluteus maximus
which is
obviously the thigh it's the largest
muscle in the human body and it's a
large powerful muscle because he has the
job of keeping the trunk in a direct
body posture so if we have the gluteus
on this list
and we have the soleus where in the
world is
spine i refuse i want my hundred
editors of the site give me my 100.
ridiculous all right
which next one what should be the next
one that i do
do better bro are you serious
sorry don't worry about it let's do the
digestive system
q1 how long is an adult small intestine
god these are hard 30 miles 30
inches 22 feet is ridiculous it's not 17
feet either
could it be 17 feet no way i'm going 30
inches
the digestive process starts in
the bathroom do not go in there it
actually starts in the mouth with your
teeth doing all the chomping and the
saliva doing the
digestion the liver's role is to mash up
food
no turn water into food
that's like a jesus thing see help the
stomach
sounds legit remove harmful stomachs
remove harmful substances from the blood
that sounds more legit you know like
alcohol and tylenol oh i'm rhyming today
god i'm on a roll oh my god how many
things am i gonna say that rhyme with
taking a poll god please don't jump into
the comment control
okay i don't have any more i'm sorry
right now dad anymore
this is getting out of control exactly
question four when they reach the
stomach
mashed when they assuming they're
referring to the mashed up food
particles
they mix with guava juice well if you
drink guava juice then maybe
gastric juices mucus or bile
mucus sounds gross but i think gastric
means stomach and if we're saying when
they reach the stomach they mix with
stomach juices
v final answer gastric means stomach
bile is made in the large intestine
no stomach no liver
yes all the above no what does digestive
system
do breaks down and handles food pumps
blood throughout the body okay if your
kid thinks your digestive system pumps
blood
we got a problem c helps you breathe the
digestive system
ain't helping you breathe it digests
helps your arms and legs move
it technically could be d and i'm one of
those yeah i'm one of those people that
argues questions on tests
but think about it if you don't get
enough nutrients from your food
can you move your arms or legs can you
breathe can you pump blood throughout
the rest of your body
i don't think so technically all of the
above your food can
spend up to this long in the small
intestine
there four years four seconds four
minutes
i'm gonna go four hours what tube moves
food
from the back of your throat to the
stomach
esophagus which organs help with the
absorption of nutrients
pancreas liver gallbladder liver heart
and spleen well first of all the heart
is not a digestive organ let's get that
out gallbladder kidneys appendix
no because if we get rid of the appendix
we're all good kidneys liver bladder
well the bladder definitely doesn't do
any absorption so we can go ahead
and put pancreas liver gallbladder the
large intestine measures about one foot
long ten foot long five foot long
hundred foot long i'm gonna say five
feet i got a 90 again
hey you're quiet now i turn around
you're gonna get wise i got the first
question wrong
how long is an adult small intestine the
answer is 22
feet i should have known this i made a
playlist for you of my
funniest gaming videos click here to
check it out